good evening
councillors ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to this extraordinary
meeting of councils
yes
is
councillor white and councillor denise
weston sure
thank you councillor freeman councillor
evans
i might have missed in that list uh
councillor mitchell is ill mitchell
thank you anybody else council carter
o'sullivan please council sullivan thank
you
and uh
as i'd forgotten can i just ask
everybody to try and use your
microphones this evening
and it does make it pick up a lot easier
on the on the youtube channel so
residents can hear what we have to say
um
this extraordinary meeting has been
specially convened to consider
conferring the title honorary alderman
to former councillors brian rigby mbe
and with stennett mbe
in recognition of exceptional service to
the council
i know that there will be it has been
agreed rather that the leader of the
council
andrew weston will introduce this matter
and move the motion
following which i will invite councillor
evans to second
and representatives of other groups to
support
in addition it has been agreed that
council lam and councillor taylor as
former ward colleagues will speak before
a vote is taken
councillor weston please
thank you chair
it is an enormous pleasure this evening
to nominate former councillors rigby and
stenit for the
um role of honorary alderman of the
borough of trafford
if i may i'll i'll talk to councillor
stennett first and then and then um
councillor rigby because councillor
stennett was a colleague of mine in the
labour group and for a decade
chair and in that time i saw somebody
absolutely committed and passionate
about their community in old trafford
somebody who worked tirelessly for all
of his residents and with distinction
distinction that has been recognized
nationally chair with the award of an
mbe and also a range of lifetime
achievement awards
for the community service particularly
given to the african caribbean community
in greater manchester wit's story is an
incredible one
i won't go through it in great detail
but you can of course read wit's
autobiography a bittersweet journey
should you wish to find out more but wit
arrived in this country with a suitcase
and i believe 50 pounds in cash and look
at what he has
achieved since
i miss him tremendously
in the council somebody with an
understated wisdom very quietly spoken
but always entirely on the money and i
remember
having a conversation with whit some
years ago when we were talking about
structural racism and the dynamics
surrounding that and he recommended a
book to me
um beyond the boundary i think it was
and it is several years since i read it
but it has stayed with me and it's
obviously linked to racism in the game
of cricket but it taught me a great deal
not just about racism but about
various forms of hatred and bigotry
something that whit has called out
throughout his life not just racism but
all forms of hatred and intolerance he
has always been such a passionate
advocate for equality first elected to
the council in 1993 a former mayor of
trafford of course
and somebody who maintained throughout
his immense service to this council a
positive approach a can-do attitude
and
just an approach really all about
dedication to community never
nasty never unpleasant always focused on
the task at hand somebody who i think
epitomizes public service and i am
delighted to have nominated wit for this
award this evening chair
but i also want to turn to councillor
rigby somebody who um although there
appears to have been some confusion with
the seating plan this evening was not
necessarily um from my side of the
chamber but somebody who i respected
immensely somebody i worked with for
years as the opposition spokesperson for
employment with brian as chair of the
committee somebody who served the
residents but
excuse me
mercy said marries and
ashton upon mersey um for decades and
somebody who i know
was tremendously respected in his
community not just for the immense
service that he gave to this council but
also for his record of service in the
education sphere in particular and you
know
i just say to both you are missed as
colleagues you are hugely respected as
colleagues we miss you but it is right
that we recognize your service this
evening and i am delighted chair to move
this motion on behalf of council thank
you
thank you councillor weston councillor
evans please
thank you chair
i'm humbled as a counselor by these two
gentlemen
and it gives me great pleasure
to be here tonight to second this motion
on behalf of the conservative group to
confer the title of honorary alderman on
these two
excellent former councillors
firstly
brian rigby mbe was a long-standing
traffic counselor and indeed first
became a member back in 1994.
brian watson has continued to be a
strong advocate for trafford's excellent
schools
and was an effective member of
trafford's planning committee and
employment committee in his time
brown is respected right across the
political divide and his contributions
were also acknowledged nationally when
he was awarded the mba for his services
to education and on a personal basis
brian has been a sense check for me
either when i served under him on the
employment committee seeking all seeking
advice on day-to-day council matters and
most of all acting as a personal
helpline when trying to understand
complex education matters primary or
secondary for this i personally thank
him
on behalf of the conservative group i
would like to thank brian for his
commitment to trafford and would like to
congratulate brian on being conferred
the title of honorary alderman of
trafford council
and secondly former mayor witt stenner
mbe first elected to traffic council way
back in 1993.
we had completed over 20 years service
prior to my election in 2014 astounding
service
and
i didn't work with whit and haven't had
the opportunity to but the respect
within this chamber um just is
obvious quite obvious and perhaps one of
uh wit's most recent achievements which
you may be aware is that whip was chosen
by residents to feature on stretchers
wall of fame to celebrate his time as
mayor in 2003-2004
and which shares the world with
lesser-known former stratford residents
such as alan carr mr scruff and even the
bee gees um
so i'd like to take this opportunity to
congratulate on behalf of the
conservative group on being conferred
the title of honorary alderman of
traffic council and i'm delighted to be
able to second this motion thank you
miss uh thank you matt
thank you councillor evans councillor
new grush would you like to support the
motion
good evening everybody
and so on behalf of the lib dem group um
because i knew both these councillors i
warmly support and endorse councillor
brian rigby and councillor witz senate
to be giving the titles of honoree
alderman for the borough of trafford
both councillor rigby and councillor
stennett
were exceptional councillors
and i had the pleasure of serving
alongside them both at trafford council
for many years
i'm delighted to support this motion
thank you very much for bringing them
forward tonight
thank you councillor brophy
councillor welton in the absence of your
colleagues would you like to support the
motion please thank you very much i'm
sure dan and uh councillor jerome and
councillor coggins would have loved to
have been here tonight to celebrate
these two very very fine
legendary i suppose you could say uh
councillors unfortunately you know our
time on the council is is is relative to
the really recent so we haven't had a
chance to to to work extensively um
with them but it's uh you know
it is inspiring to see people who have
been on the council for so long and done
so much and i think it gives us all
something to look up to um so yeah very
much support this motion thank you
thank you councillor welton
council lamb please we'd like to
support uh thank you very much uh mayor
uh well it is of course uh as a as a
ward uh colleague or uh award colleague
of former councillor uh rigby uh that
i'm uh privileged to stand up and and uh
you know support this uh proposal um a
lot has already been said so there's
always a great risk here of uh
repetition but uh nothing wrong with uh
doubt when we're talking about uh
council rigby in particular uh who i
want to say just a few words about
um and i know that i speak for my
colleague councillor wetton as well when
i say that uh you know with nearly two
decades
of working together in the actual mersey
area we saw at first hand
if you like how dedicated
brian was to the people of the ward
you know nothing got left behind
absolutely
diligent in his attention to ward work
and you know that's something that
doesn't always get noticed but it
certainly got noticed by an awful lot of
residents in ashton upon mersey
the citation talks about education and a
lot has already been said about that
but i don't think it needs to be
underestimated at all just how
passionate brian is about education and
if you look at the citation you can see
the evidence there that supports
that
so
it's a
you know a great honor to support the
conferring of the honorary alderman and
i think this really is an important
feature of our civic life because i
think what it does is to make sure that
there is a continuing link and
connection between
former councillors of the great
experience of both council rigby and
councillor whit stennett and others who
have gone before them it ensures that a
continuing link uh between the council
our civic life
and people with great
experience uh in
in our great bullet of trafford here
thank you very much
you know i i do of course support the uh
nominations
thank you councilor lam councillor
taylor please
thank you mayor
i would like to offer my sincere
congratulations to councillor winston at
mb on being made an honorary alderman of
the borough of trafford
i had the immense privilege of working
alongside witt for 13 years as my fellow
councillor in clifford ward
wit is a stalwart of the community in
old trafford and is held in the highest
regard by everyone including myself of
course
wit embodies
the qualities of a brilliant community
leader and public servant
i would like to thank whit personally
for his friendship kindness and
generosity to to myself
i've learned i learned so much from him
about community relationships fairness
and inequality
he's a wise and wonderful teacher
sadly wit i am no wiser about the game
of cricket
this award award is so richly deserved
and a fitting accolade for someone who
has been an exceptional champion for our
borough regionally nationally and
globally
i'm sure everyone here
will congratulate you wit
and share share with me in thanking you
for your exceptional service to trafford
and offer you and your family wit our
warmest regards
it's an immense privilege and an honour
to commend councillor stennett for this
award thank you mayor
thank you councillor taylor
i will now put the motion to the council
that being of the opinion that former
councillor brian rigby mbe
and former councillor whit stenit mbe
have rendered eminent services as past
members of the council
one of the provisions of the local
government act 1972
hereby converse that confers the title
of honorary alderman upon former
councillor brian rigby mbe and former
councillor with stenet mbe in
recognition for their exceptional
service to the borough of trafford
all those in
the favor is agreed
i will now present honorary alderman
rigby and honorary
alderman stennett with a scroll to
commemorate the occasion and we have
flowers for mrs rigby and mrs stennit
photographs will be taken
to your face
so
um
i'll take some outside
pictures
here now
mr
channel
christians
oh
yes
i'm going to take a photo of this
uh
um
everybody settle down please um
i would now like to invite our new
honorary alderman to respond to the
council
honoree alderman rigby please
can you hear me
thank you
um i'm aware tonight mr mayor
members that um it's not enough for long
speeches
um you've got a council meeting coming
up and i know you can't wait
and my wife's just said on the way home
i'll buy you a drink so
the the night's getting better
um can i say a really special thanks to
leaders
um parties and to my former colleague
john lamb for
their very kind words
and for you members for the way you've
received it
receive those words
um
i just like to say that during my time
as a member traffic council
i always thought it was a privilege
as well as a deep honor
to be represent the people in this
amazing borough
you know i came here 50 years ago
from that little village called
warrington
and um i've really enjoyed every single
moment
i met my wife
so it doesn't get better than that does
it
um
yes and especially it's been referred to
in education
education was always special to me
not that i was particularly smart at
school just the opposite but i was born
during the war
and the only time
i was warm and the only time i got hot
meal was at school
after the war
and if it hadn't been for education
um
i don't know what i'd have done it was
there were happy times and sad times
because in those days a lot of the
pupils
had no fathers returning
so school
when i retired
from the police force
and i stumbled into education
uh it's doubled into
at first education yes and then council
it gave me the opportunity
to ensure that
children irrespective of their
background
and personal circumstances
had every opportunity to succeed
that is so important and i know members
here share that belief with me
it's a very special occasion for me
obviously and i'm deeply moved but it's
also a special occasion for marion
um
i say without fear of contradiction
that i couldn't have done what i did
being going out in the morning early
coming back at nine ten o'clock night
after night week after week year after
year
without my wife's encouragement
it was invaluable particularly in those
times when things don't go particularly
well
things get grow rough
the words of encouragement
were invaluable
and i'd like to thank her publicly
mr mayor
thanks for your kind words
and thank you members
[Applause]
honorary alderman stennett
would you like to say a few words please
mayor
counselor lawrence walsh
and your escort mrs rachel walsh
members and officers of council
members of the clergy
distinguished guests good evening
first let me begin
by giving thanks
to the creator for granting me with
longevity
to be sharing this defining moment with
you thanks is also due to my wife gwen
of 60 years
for her dedication
symbolic that behind every successful
man
is a successful woman
thanks it's due to my two daughters
patricia
and angela
and my three granddaughters nikita
shanique and imogen
who typifies in every sense
that in the struggles
families are important
in keeping the human spirit alive
and full of vigor
on the 21st of may 2003 when i stood
here
to be invested with the necessary
requirements
we fit in the office of mayor
and first citizen of the borough of
trafford whose motto is all first to
that which is good
i was not sparing and recognizing
and acknowledging
the overwhelming support from the entire
borough
that made my achievement possible
the same is applicable this evening
to my fellow counselor brian rigby
i salute you
you're a decent human being an officer
and a gentleman
no individual group
reached the same level of awareness
at the same time
and history and events
will continue to remind us
that whatever are the reasons why people
live
from one country to cycle in another
country
all of us
of migrant and immigrant heritage
and as such
it becomes necessary
that in order to leave legacies
we must strive to create level playing
fields where our contributions
can be recognized
and acknowledged
and i dare say
that while some
rivers have been crossed
there are still many more to be crossed
in the meanwhile i will continue to
serve with dedication
decorum and dignity ladies and gentlemen
enjoy the rest of the evening and i
thank you
[Applause]
on behalf of the council i would like to
thank brian witz for their kind words
and congratulate them both
on being conferred as honorary alderman
of the borough
that then concludes this meeting i would
like to thank all the members and guests
for your attendance
since we now have a full council meeting
before us before us
i have invited new aldermen to my civic
reception on friday the 8th of april
where we will have further opportunity
to celebrate their achievements
thank you everybody you'd like to stand